[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 9 octobre bienvenue
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tva 78
c'est le tour d'horizon de l'actualité
de saint quentin et des yvelines tout de
suite les titres une monnaie locale pour
la vallée de chevreuse et les communes
environnantes la racine a officiellement
été lancée ce week-end au mesnil saint
denis
il est désormais possible de payer avec
cette devise h et 50 commerçants du
territoire et de nombreuses yvelinois
étaient présents pour changer leurs
euros le la 15e semaine du handicap
s'est terminé dimanche à montigny le
bretonneux elle visait notamment à
favoriser l'activité professionnelle
avec un forum andy recrutement
entreprises et demandeurs d'emploi
étaient amenés à se rencontrer dans un
format convivial et puis à la fin de ce
journal le coup de coeur culture sera
musical de l'aca hall avec les soeurs
jumelles 10 pays
elles se produisent ce vendredi à la
salle du prix ce mail en cours nous
recevons également tout à l'heure deux
membres de l'association france
parkinson 78 elle organise une
conférence sur les troubles n'ont
menteur non moteurs de la maladie
ce samedi à versailles est depuis
quelques semaines l'association à la
racine s'est donné pour objectif de
créer une monnaie locale après une phase
de test en juin à chevreuse et ses
alentours est la racine a donc été
officiellement lancée ce week-end les
précisions de marignac lee chennault et
de nicolas d'andré 1 euro égale une
racine les billets ne seront pas
acceptés dans votre banque mais chez 50
professionnels du parc naturel régional
de la haute vallée de chevreuse
on voulait prendre à avec plaisir c'est
une question de renforcement de
l'économie locale de manière générale
par exemple moi je vais acheter ma
baguette en racines
c'est chez mon boulanger le boulanger
pourrait acheter sa farine dans dans une
ferme locale dans un moulin locale et le
payant racines et c'est comme ça qu'on
démultiplie finalement la force d'une
monnaie locale en circulaire dimanche 7
octobre la monnaie locale faisait son
lancement officiel particuliers et
professionnels étaient nombreux à venir
au mesnil saint denis pour changer leurs
euros et favoriser une économie
circulaire savent nous que
systématiquement l'économie locale les
gens échangent entre eux à partir de
cette monnaie locale beaucoup plus qu'il
ne le ferait à partir de leurs voix il
faut qu'on compense un petit peu
commerces locaux donc il faut qu'on
continue aussi est un people
les commerçants et les
les organismes de la balle et à
développer cette manne est plus que les
commerçants se sont aussi les communes
qui commencent à s'intéresser à la
racine à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines mais
cinéma municipal le cratère acceptent
désormais la monnaie locale toutes les
possibilités qui nous permettent de
renforcer l'activité comme une ennemie
quand en tout cas de la maintenir sont
mises en oeuvre donc la racine fait
partie de ces cordes à l'arc d arnaud
lechien pour aider nos commerçants
l'association souhaite désormais étendre
sa racine sur un territoire plus large
objectif de 1000 adhérents fin 2019
contre 350 aujourd'hui et depuis 1997 la
loi impose aux entreprises de plus de 20
à salarié employé au moins six personnes
deux personnes en situation de handicap
et des travailleurs et sociétés qui ont
souvent du mal à se rencontrer c'est
pour faciliter cette mise en relation
avec a été organisé le forum
andy recrutement la troisième édition se
tenait vendredi en mairie de montigny le
bretonneux
un rendez vous dans le cadre de la
quinzième semaine du handicap changer
les regards sur le handicap la ville de
montigny le bretonneux s'y attelle
depuis 15 ans avec sa semaine dédiée
favoriser notamment l'insertion
professionnelle avec ce troisième forum
andy recrutement organisé avec pôle
emploi et l'organisme cap emploi 78
c'est pas parce qu'on est handicapé
qu'on ne peut pas faire des choses et
pour nous l'objectif depuis 15 ans et de
changer le regard sur le handicap et que
les personnes handicapées soit
intégré dans la ville et que tout se
passe bien pour elle neuf entreprises du
territoire était présente pour
rencontrer les demandeurs d'emploi parmi
elles cette société basée à versailles
qui recrutent exclusivement des
personnes en situation de handicap
on a la difficulté quelques ajustements
de rencontrer la population de personnes
en situation de handicap et aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment de rencontrer sur notre
bassin de 78 des personnes qui pourront
travailler sur 78 tout sur l'île de
france donc c'est très important pour
nous d'être présent parmi la centaine de
personnes venue au forum même constat
rencontrer un employeur sur place est
une réelle opportunité dans un contexte
où obtenir un entretien d'embauché
s'apparente à un parcours du combattant
ça facilite le contact on n'a pas à le
dire et s'est beaucoup mieux passé bon
tout de suite qu'on dit travailleur avec
un handicap et ont connu un handicap et
tout de suite ça mais c'est difficile
effectivement de d'atteindre à jusqu'à
la rencontre de l'employeur ou alors
faut parfois avoir des cds qui
ressemblent à des moutons à cinq pattes
un nouveauté cette année au forum trois
ateliers dont un de sensibilisation sur
le langage des signes animé par
l'association harris est la surdité dans
le monde des entreprises posent
plusieurs questions en premier lieu la
communication
mais ensuite comment on peut solutionner
ça en fait en informant
les patrons les chefs d'entreprise en
faisant découvrir le monde de sourds en
fait et permettent de faire des ponts
entre chaque culture en fait c'est comme
ça que l'entreprise peut avancer c'est
pas impossible tout est possible en fait
l'an passé le taux de chômage chez les
personnes en situation de handicap
atteignait 19 % près du double du
pourcentage global de demandeurs
d'emploi et pour clôturer la semaine du
handicap à montigny le bretonneux c'est
un rendez vous régulier le triathlon de
l'espérance qui fêtait dimanche sa
neuvième édition avec philippe candeloro
yvan le bolloc'h et l'actrice ali k del
sol elle lancé par l'association média
handicap le triathlon propose trois
défis à réaliser en situation de
handicap parcours fauteuil basket en
fauteuil et des figues ou les yeux
bandés des intervieweurs en herbe
thibault hélène sébastien josé et alizée
ont pu également poser leurs questions
aux stars présentes le but c'est de
faire évoluer l'image de la personne
handicapée dans les médias j'accueille
sur ce plateau deux invités philippe
lascols c'est catherine spsl bonsoir à
vous deux fronts soir merci à d'être
présent ce soir alors vous êtes
respectivement délégués et déléguées
adjointe de france parkinson 78
le comité des yvelines organise samedi
prochain une conférence sur les troubles
n'ont un moteur de la maladie c'est à
l'auditorium de la clinique de la porte
verte à versailles avant d'y venir et de
parler de cette conférence reprécisons
peut-être pour donner toutes les clés à
nos téléspectateurs ce qu'est la maladie
de parkinson est une maladie
neurodégénérative
alors c'est la deuxième maladie
neurodégénérative après la maladie
d'alzheimer
elle touche environ deux cent mille deux
cent huit personnes donc
si on fait le ratio sur notre
département c'est à peu près 4000
personnes qui sont qui sont qui sont
atteintes
alors l'association france parkinson a
pour mission principalement de soutenir
ces malades de les informer sur la
maladie de financer la recherche
on a financé près de des programmes de
recherche à hauteur de près de 4
millions l'an dernier de sensibiliser
opinion changer le regard sur par
rapport à la maladie
on participera sur un bateau france
parkinson sur la prochaine route du rhum
d'accord et mobiliser les pouvoirs
publics en ce moment on a un gros sujet
on a un médicament important dans le
traitement de la maladie
le sim net qui en rupture
d'approvisionnement c'est prévu pour
durer plus de six mois et donc ça nous
inquiète beaucoup parce que beaucoup de
des patients en fait sont traités avec
ce médicament
voilà est donc sûre sur les symptômes de
cette maladie il ya des symptômes
visibles et aux errements visuel et
symptômes usines que ce que tout le
monde connaît par exemple le tremblement
souvent la manie de parkinson est
associé aux tremblements
mais y'a pas que le tremblement a en
fait il ya un triptyque un haut niveau
des symptômes moteurs donc les propres
les tremblements la lenteur la lenteur
dans l'exécution des des mouvements et
et la raideur voilà et la raideur qui
peut être très importante
alors il ya ces troubles moteurs il ya
les troubles moteurs dont on va parler
juge dando qui est le sujet de cette
conférence de sujet d'un samedi juste
avant catherine spsl vous êtes vous même
atteindre delà de la maladie de
parkinson comment vous vivez avec cette
maladie jt des d'hostilité diagnostiqué
il ya dix ans et petit à petit de tout
pendant la place qu'on appelle la lune
de miel
ça s'est très bien passé je mets
médicaments fonctionnait à merveille
et puis depuis un an ça commence à être
plus dur je suis fatigué j'ai
l'impression de n'être plus figé c'est
plus lourd c'est plus c'est un peu plus
douloureux aussi au niveau des
articulations et la lenteur du cerveau
on commence à me poser des problèmes
donc ça ça devient de plus en plus oui
et non
je pense que pour la plupart des gens ça
devient plus compliqué on parlait de
traitement est ce que les traitements
progresse on connaît mieux aujourd'hui
cette cette maladie alors qu'il est
depuis trop depuis 30 ans a largement
progressé 1 les neurologues ont à
disposition d'une batterie de
médicaments mais qui qui n'ont qu'une
durée limitée en fait un les symptômes
ils sont limités à une action
c'est-à-dire la dopamine apporter la
dopamine auxerre au cerveau mais
malheureusement ça touche plusieurs
endroits du cerveau déjà ce qui
complique les choses
il ya d'autres neurotransmetteurs ce
sont ces c
ce qui est utile par exemple pour la
dopamine un mouvement y en a d'autres
dans le cerveau qui disparaissent aussi
on rappelle vous organiser cette
conférence pardon samedi sur les
troubles nos moteurs de parkinson alors
4e spéciale vous êtes particulièrement à
l'organisation de cette conférence
pourquoi pourquoi la proposer on disait
tout à l'heure l'idée c'est de
sensibiliser on ne sait pas forcément
qui a des troubles mon moteur de cette
maladie justement dans le passé on a
surtout parlé des troubles moteurs
maintenant on a oublié une catégorie qui
est très importante qui sont justement
qui est justement ces troubles moteurs
qui est qui comprennent aussi bien le
piccolo des troubles psychologiques des
troubles cognitifs et comportementaux et
puis d'autres choses comme le sommeil
comme la digestion comme lors de
l'odorat il a perdu l'odorat avaya est
vraiment c'est extrêmement variés et la
dopamine des maps les médicaments qu'on
propose s'en sont beaucoup moins et
agissent beaucoup moins bien c'est
important de dire finie place colts qui
avaient des symptômes qui ne se voit pas
de cette maladie de parkinson
oui oui tout à fait la visite bien sûr
il faut entendre la parole du malade
pour pour le soigner finalement il faut
qu'il s'exprime
est ce qu'elle est traitée par les
spécialistes cette cet aspect non
moteurs alors il ya certains aspects qui
sont traités parce que souvent la main
c'est une maladie neurodégénérative donc
c'est une maladie qui est dur à vivre
donc il ya souvent de problèmes
psychologiques des dépressions qui sont
associés à la maladie
et c'est important que c'est que c'est
tout cela soit soit traité également
et alors c'est compliqué parce que
souvent les
les passants 10 aubry ils ont déjà
beaucoup de médicaments à prendre on
leur rajoute des médicaments pour
traiter d'autres santo qui sont connexes
à la maladie ces contes d'ailleurs
contraire contradictoires ça peut
arriver à être contradictoires des
traitements sont très difficiles à
personnaliser à ajuster il faut vraiment
du temps il faut que le neurologue plats
ne sont vraiment beaucoup de temps pour
mettre au point cette conférence de
samedi elle s'adresse akiyo aux malades
à leur famille un public aussi plus
large peut-être aux malades et à leurs
proches
un atout ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont
de peu de loin intéressés par la mali
donc on a des soignants qui sont qui
sont donc décliné parce que oui on a
parlé des neurologues mais il faut aussi
parler de tout ce qui entoure en fait le
malade parce que c'est ce qui est
important pour le malade par rapport aux
raiders ou douleurs musculaires et ses
terrasses et la kinésithérapie
l'orthophonie parce qu'il ya souvent des
problèmes d'élocution qui sont associés
à la maladie
donc tous et tous ces professions de la
santé oms a un certain nombre qui sont
déjà inscrits
on a alors il faut faire attention parce
qu'on a on est un peu débordé par notre
succès on a fait une liste de pré
inscription on est déjà sans d'autres
salles 140 personnes donc oui on peut
encore accueillir du monde mais elle en
intervenant qui est un psychologue qui
est spécialisée dans sept ans attend son
domaine s'appelle thierry guetta il a il
a écrit en avec une neurologue des
livres qui s'adresse aussi bien aux
malades cas les dents vous êtes venus
d'ailleurs avec le deux de ses livres km
à la caméra voilà tirs hier guetta qui a
publié ces deux libres et je pense que
apprendre recevoir de l'information sur
sa sueur sur ces sujets là peut
améliorer la qualité de vie des familles
et aider les personnels soignants à une
pour une meilleure prise en charge aussi
malade sur la forme comment ça va se
dérouler donc une conférence les
personnes pourront poser des étais son
lit des seniors bien sûr et du coup vous
disiez vous êtes victime de votre succès
il ya beaucoup d'inscriptions nos vies
on a déjà plus de 100 inscriptions sur
et donc
voilà donc ça veut dire que derrière sa
rencontre un public donc ça veut dire
que c'était important de faire ce genre
de conférence 1 et qu on a tapé juste
tout en sachant que beaucoup de patients
ont du mal à se déplacer
donc c'est très bien que cultiver 78 en
parle on peut s'inscrire sur pour les
quelques places qu'il reste bien sûr de
sûr bien sûr qu'il ya toutes les
informations bien sûr sur le site de
france parkinson qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
cette conférence bacon importe en fait
de la connaissance à ceux qui sont
présents un pur qui vivent un peu de
mieux la maladie en la comprenant
peut-être un peu mieux
et puis en essayant d'être au courant de
certaines choses en disant voilà ça
m'arrive pas qu'à moi sarine aussi aux
autres on a des solutions et ser a pris
des conseils d'éric précieux pour mieux
vivre la mode
alors si j'ai quelques secondes alesi st
le comité france parkinson et c'est
d'être au plus proche en fait des
malades et de leurs familles et donc on
essaie de créer deux des antennes sur
chaque arrondissement est donc là on
avait créé une sûrement y en a une sur
fort que saint germain est là maintenant
on essaye de créer une antenne sur ce
rambouillet évidemment au départ et un
comité sur versailles et au minimum on
se réunit une fois par mois à ce qu'on
appelle réunion mensuelle des changes
c'est des échanges entre malades et dans
pour échanger sur la maladie sur ce que
tous les à côtés de la maladie et c'est
des invités donc une association qui se
développe sur sur les yvelines et on
rappelle que cette conférence ce samedi
7 à la clinique de la porte verte à
versailles à partir de 15h merci avec
catherine est spécial et et philippe
lascols ces droits est avec nous
déléguée adjointe et déléguée du comité
des yvelines de france parkinson
avoir un enfant est une étape importante
dans une vie c'est aussi un
bouleversement pour les parents pour
répondre à leurs interrogations le
premier salon de la parentalité s'est
tenue samedi c'était attrape un
reportage de mélanie poker et manon
varaldo chant prénatal coach pour
parents réflexologie sophrologie
telles étaient les stands présents à
l'occasion du premier salon de la
parentalité du bien-être à trappes
il est organisé par à cali l'association
des créateurs de lien inter
générationnel en collaboration avec
saint quentin en yvelines
le parent parfait n'existe pas mais par
contre le parent est tous les jours
confronté à des questionnements des
doutes des difficultés des joies des
peines qui le confronte à ses propres
limites et du coup savoir qu'il peut
comme on dire être soutenu dans ses
actions au quotidien avec ses enfants
et bien ça peut être très aidant pour
lui encore faut-il qu'ils sachent vers
qui se retourner d'où l'utilité de ce
salon pour nous faire connaître auprès
lui lors de ce salon d'hiver
professionnels de soutien à la
parentalité du bien-être sont présents
pour répondre aux difficultés et
questions des parents c'est plutôt
vraiment revoir
qu'est-ce que dans le qu'est ce que moi
je fais qui a une incidence sur le
comportement de l'enfant
est-ce que je suis pas en train
d'empirer la situation quand l'enfant
vit des difficultés et donc qu'est-ce
que je peux faire - en tant qu'adulte
pour améliorer la relation et surtout le
comportement finalement nos forums des
ateliers étaient organisés afin de
permettre une découverte concrète de
certaines techniques ou pratiques
l'idée c'est de rentrer en communication
avec son enfant déjà in utero puis
ensuite quand il est né et plus tard
quand il grandit en fait via la musique
et le toucher l'association à cali
espère pouvoir renouveler cette
expérience l'année prochaine avec un
deuxième salon nous vous en parlions en
mars avec cette visite dans les yvelines
le projet européen résident se poursuit
avec la deuxième rencontre
transnationales en suède est les
délégations française allemande
hollandaise grec polonaises et suédoises
elles sont nombreuses qui participent à
ce programme se sont retrouvés des
échanges sur la thématique de la
ruralité
nicolas landry la maison de l'europe des
yvelines au pays des vikings
la délégation française du programme
ride il a passé trois jours en suède
read it un projet européen financé par
le programme erasmus plus avec comme
objectif d'échanger sur les politiques
publiques et actions citoyennes mises en
place dans les zones rurales dans tous
les villages où les communautés qu'on a
pu visiter et des témoignages qui nous
ont été présentés on voit de très jeunes
femmes investi en politique des
personnes âgées encore hyper actif dans
leur communauté et une vraie volonté de
travailler ensemble et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui peut être très
inspirant pour nous ce qui est frappant
en suède notamment c'est l'espace qui
l'on est la difficulté qu'ils ont les
familles à s'installer dans les zones
rurales
alors que visiblement d'après ce qu'on
nous a dit il ya une vraie demande et
une vraie volonté de venir habiter à la
campagne la campagne suédoise réserve
parfois des surprises comme
deux fermes vikings restaurer basée à or
sound à une ferme au coeur d'une action
citoyenne lisa anderson fait découvrir
l'histoire de ce territoire aux
touristes suédois et étrangers depuis le
début c'était un projet de la communauté
d'agglomération de seine viken pour
essayer de faire baisser le chômage
donc ils ont essayé de trouver des
solutions pour créer des emplois pour
les habitants
un exemple d'une initiative locale et
citoyenne les 24 personnes des
différentes délégations ont pu partager
leur expérience avec notamment le modèle
suédois
nous avons quelques informations
quelques connaissances sur la manière
dont est mise en place le développement
des zones rurales en suède que ce soit
au niveau national régional ou local
vous ne pouvez pas développer si vous
n'avez pas les zones rurales avec lui
c'est très important quand vous parlez
de développement des villes de
développement des villes c'est aussi le
développement rural
mais ce peut être difficile parfois de
discuter que les élus nationaux de cela
parce qu'ils doivent comprendre le
problème et doivent comprendre que nous
avons besoin de différents types de
mesures pour développer différents types
de région et c'est très important
d'avoir des prises de décisions
décentralisée de la sdc shining
prochain rendez vous pour les yvelinois
du projet riz dit à rhodes en grèce du
11 au 15 avril 2019 un mot de ce sport
on connaît la composition de l'équipe de
france de cyclisme sur piste pour la
coupe du monde la première manche de la
compétition se déroule du 19 au 21
octobre au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines est les spectateurs
pourront voir les multiples champions du
monde françois pervis grégory baugé ou
encore la future pépite mathilde de gros
présentation avec michael et me doro et
patrie jacques de dixmude les pistards
de l'équipe de france était sous les
feux des projecteurs ce jeudi 4 octobre
la fédération a dévoilé officiellement
les noms des sportifs qui participeront
à l'étape de coupe du monde organisée du
19 au 21 octobre au vélotour national de
saint quentin en yvelines
vous pouvez voir dans l'équipe de france
il ya des comores expérimentés qui ont
déjà participé à plusieurs jeux
plusieurs champions du monde et puis des
jeunes donc ça c'est également vrai en
endurance notamment chez les filles
donc on doit de scorer dans toutes les
disciplines ski ce qui est possible oui
dans les anciens l'autre alors au tour
de grégory baugé neuf fois champion du
monde et la présence de ligne montrent
un françois pervis cette fois couronné
au niveau mondial ce dernier nourrit de
grandes ambitions sur cette compétition
à 33 ans il faut pas se louper puisque
dans deux ans il va falloir avoir assez
de points pour avoir tous les quotas au
niveau de déchets olympique donc c'est
très important
la nouvelle génération sera quant à elle
symbolisé par deux visages sébastien
vigier 21 ans et mathilde de gros 19 ans
ses dernières va endosser le rôle de
favorite sur cette compétition à
domicile après un titre européen cet été
c'est énorme pour moi ça va être la
première fois que je vis une grosse
compétition ici à domicile donc voilà va
falloir essayer de ne pas trop se mettre
la pression ça va être une chose
nouvelle pour moi on va voir comment je
réagis j'espère que ça se passera bien
et j'espère que je donne enfin que tout
cas j'aurai une belle médaille pour mes
amis et ma famille cette équipe de
france devrait se produire devant plus
de dix mille spectateurs sur ces trois
jours de compétition vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
allez un peu de respiration en ouvre une
fenêtre culturelle dans ce journal
[Musique]
bonsoir mélanie poquet on sait grégory
ribéry veut dire jumeaux en yoruba la
langue africaine parler au nigeria bénin
et togo lisa kind et naomi dias des
soeurs jumelles l'ont choisi comme nom
de scène
elles se produisent à la fin de la
semaine sur la scène du prisme
d'elancourt et c'est votre coup de coeur
oui un coup de coeur inattendu grégory
car un jour cg déploie ribéy en les
écoutant à la radio alors c'est en duo
les akan et naomi diaz deux soeurs elles
sont nées à paris d'un père cubain et
d'une mère franco vénézuélienne et si
leur nom ne semble peu connu en france
encore elles ont pourtant une très belle
reconnaissance à l'international elles
sont repérés par adel price ou encore
beyoncé et leur musique est un métissage
de la pop du hip hop de l'électro
hypnotique et des chants yoruba un
extrait le clash
[Musique]
what you
trois grandes à fumer
[Musique]
alors ça c'est un extrait de leur
dernier album h et un album que le
public pourra découvrir au prisme des
l'encours des titres qui donne envie de
danser milo il faut aussi tendre
l'oreille
elle chante des titres sur des textes
engagés chilly gonzales qui est
compositeur et musicien canadien mais
chelle négo rossello qui est rappeuse
américaine et des mots simples et d'une
certaine michelle obama
l'ex première dame américaine alors
j'arrête avec les noms célèbres ce
serait réduire ses jumelles assez simple
collaboration et behi ce sont avant tout
deux voix superbe profonde et sensuelle
leurs morceaux sont en mouvement avant
tout envoûtant écoutez
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour les écouter direction le prisme
d'elancourt vendredi 12 octobre à 20h30
merci mélanie pour cette chronique on
vous retrouve dans un instant dans votre
émission le 7-8 culture et ce sera
d'ailleurs l'un des sujets de cette
émission depuis 25 ans maintenant un
festival de bande dessinée est au
programme à buc le week-end dernier plus
de 8000 visiteurs ont répondu présent et
il y en a un qui ne rateraient ce rendez
vous pour rien au monde nicolas landry
l'a suivi est le récit est signée de
vous mélanie poké prend une série au
long cours comme thorgal un hyper sa
famille part à sa recherche il a
retroussé son fiancé qui disparaît entre
bédéphiles on parle bien sûr de bd au 25
ans didier de bernardi n'a raté qu'un
seul festival de but cette année encore
il fait partie des premiers de la file
aujourd'hui c'est qu'un certain
difficile des auteurs qui sont
difficiles à avoir qui sont rares et
donc bah il faut être dans les premiers
sinon après on passe la journée pour un
seul auteur didier espère compléter sa
collection il possède plus de 5000
ouvrages
une passion qu'il partage avec des
auteurs devenus pour certains des amis
un regard amusé et attendri aussi parce
que c'est c'est le phénomène des des
gens qui sont vraiment passionnés par le
par la bd et où et didier en fait j'ai
connu lors d'une dédicace au château de
versailles organisé pour le personnel
par un autre gars de fagard de
surveillants chez pas comment il faut
dire de versailles qui nous avait fait
venir didier est un amoureux des comics
et de la bd franco-belge ce dimanche il
veut rencontrer olivier choir ce
dessinateur français je vais connu par
les séries de s'appeler l'inspecteur
bayard
j'étais destiné aux enfants qui
paraissait dans okapi et olivier jeu
farce
il devenu le dessinateur est un
dessinateur de la série spirou donc
maintenant il est beaucoup plus connu
qu'avant quand ils disent mais juste
l'inspecteur bayard où c'était facile de
le voir là maintenant c'est un peu plus
compliqué je mettais au temps de jeu
rien aujourd'hui les choses que j'ai
fait avant qualité cette dédicace va
rejoindre la collection de didier ce
passionné en possède aujourd'hui plus de
c'est la fin du journal belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]